how's it going guys welcome to my
channel episode do I have that I don't
have episodes I have little episode bye
guys so yesterday or day before
yesterday depending on when I get this
video a trailer for the remake of it hit
the Internet people were like to talk
about the trailer but I had to review
ghost in the shell' I didn't really have
the time and since the Internet in
YouTube is ultimately a very
here-and-now thing I don't know if you
guys are kind of over the it trailer
right now you don't give a [ __ ] but what
I'm about to say so I don't know if I'm
wasting my time I don't know if it's
worth it so let's make it worth it let's
have fun so the trailer for it drop some
people like Alex like [ __ ] as we were
like I does not look like [ __ ] I think
it's cool like I maybe I'm one of those
people have always been so interested in
an it remake when the picture of
Pennywise hit the internet I was like he
looks cool so I see the trailer I'm like
yeah loosen eight maybe it's because and
once I say this is just really know
taking it back this is out there now on
the internet that version of it just
never scared me I don't know if I saw it
too late in life I thought when I was in
junior high I don't know if that's when
I was supposed to say I don't want to
know who thought like aged ten and under
like yeah it was the nightmare inducing
thing of my life who does I guess junior
High's past that point and in the world
were remakes and reboots are a dime a
dozen there are movies out there that
could benefit from a remake or reboot I
think it is one of them never read the
book also so what I'm about I couldn't
even about the theorizing we're going to
be like idiot he's just clearly never at
the bug not a secret out I haven't read
the books are sad it shows Georgie with
his little boat a little paper boat that
goes down and in the rain if anyways
based possibly the sewer is like a house
down here thus we see something is
terrorizing this town and apparently the
kids in it what I remember the old one
though the story of it is the group of
adults come together and it's showing
what happened to them as a child with
this Pennywise clown and them as adults
also dealing with it two different
pockets of time this one doesn't show
them as adults it just shows kids I
don't know if there's going to be kids
through the entire movie I don't know if
there's going to be to it movies for if
one is them as kids it too never a turn
when they come back as adults no idea a
stranger things was huge they're like oh
we can just have kids carry a story like
this let's do that oh really this
trailer has some great horror imagery it
really does that weird creepy little
sound that baby baby
there's that scene with the slide
projector it's just it's great it's just
visual horror that I like and it's
rather than like oh it's in the sewer
system that's where it lives with slide
projectors like and it just keeps going
faster and faster and faster and they're
all freaking out and it's going so fast
that it's moving like a movie because
for those of you who might not know
that's how this works if you're watching
this then you're seeing that happen
frame by frame by frame in succession
that makes movement you guys didn't do
that with post-it notes like drug really
brutal cartoons decapitate and more will
come back in those flippin so fast ones
like this family photo it goes up to the
what looks like the mom and then like
the hair is moving in his Pennywise
aisle just staring at it with his
shit-eating smile those of you want to
know what my flirt game looks like boom
that was just great visual horror that
was a great moment because you're like
it's penny wise manipulating the slides
right now but was he actually standing
there when that picture happened and
he's just revealing that I don't know
but that really makes me uneasy penny
wise is a creepy little [ __ ] I'll tell
you that I mean Tim Curry Pennywise was
looked a lot taller this dude lose about
half his height half my height maybe
that's what he's supposed to be supposed
to be just like impish little demon
thing I really need to read that book
they said he runs at the camera like few
people in the comment section you were
some funny [ __ ] out there people in
the comment section that rather were
putting context and running like that no
was there something like Ronald McDonald
when he finds out you're eating Burger
King hey Ronald this whopper is pretty
good I don't know it was really funny I
thought this is a good first trailer for
it every now how these things are going
to work out point is the it trailer have
you seen it what did you think about it
what's your favorite Stephen King novel
that you've ever read went books on this
one for me needful things I read that
when I was in high school awesome I
couldn't put it down as you know Stephen
King books they're you know thin
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you
[Music]